[Music]
i just miss her i feel so bad because
she's
lonely kris jenner breaks down in tears
talking about quarantine in a sneak peek
at the upcoming season of keeping up
with the kardashians
the famous fam jumps on a group facetime
call while self-isolating at the
beginning of the coronavirus outbreak
we're at another week of quarantine it's
going to be a while
until we get together for a big family
dinner again
so i decided to have the whole family
come together and do a video call
yeah look closely and you'll see the
whole crew
chris kim scott chloe and kendall
there's so many of us and they admit
it's been hard to adjust to life at home
i don't know about you guys but i have
good days and bad days but it's about
just not being able to see you guys i
get really
sad for khloe the biggest struggle has
been the uncertainty of it all
i feel like i've been in here for a year
the whole
thing is just hard and it's like how
long is this going to go on for and
what's going on
a lot longer than we think that's when
kim
asks her mom how their grandma mary jo
is holding up
and chris breaks down she's
good but you guys should facetime with
her because she gets
kind of lonely the last time i saw her
like three weeks ago i took her for a
little ride before they really
shut everything down and we just drive
around you know
to some familiar spots i literally went
home and just
it was good in the months leading up to
the coronavirus outbreak
mj suffered an injury and has been stuck
at home longer than the rest of us
i just miss her i feel so bad because
she's
lonely and she's been in that apartment
for
i don't know two months because of her
fracture
i really miss mj a lot
we always have things planned and talk
about where we're gonna
go and what we're gonna do the longer
this goes
i'm feeling a sense of
loss because i can't be with her but the
kardashians weren't just separated from
each other they've been separated from
their crew too
and they've had to shoot a lot of the
upcoming season
themselves in the new clip we get a peek
at chris and coco's self-taped
confessionals
i just want to show you guys that in the
guest room we have set up a confessional
and i still am filming keeping up with
the kardashians but
shot all on iphones back in april
kim shared a little behind the scenes
look at her home setup
i am the camera person i am the lighting
person i am hair and makeup
um so i'm going to try to figure this
out and she revealed how they're making
it work
there is clear instructions
it says power on here i know i can do
this
power on
okay the monitor should go on there it
is
we have our lights okay there should you
should see two levels on the monitor
uh labeled one and two and if you're
talking they should be bouncing up and
down
okay one and two i don't see that
one and two am i blind that work from
home struggle
is so real it's a lot of us filming but
in our individual homes
either on tripods where you just set up
and go and it was
very different and awkward and we're so
used to being in each other's faces so
it's
different and in july chloe dished on
shooting the show without their crew
during a chat with siriusxm hits one's
the morning mashup
i thought i pushed record once and i
didn't i'm sitting there like having a
whole
confessional to the camera and yeah
nothing happened i just kind of [ __ ]
[Music]
up